so we have to ask Mike yes have you ever
peed in your pants in space yes we
didn't call to UCD we called it the mag
the mag the maximum absorbency garment
oh there was a diaper diaper yes we were
a diaper on launch and entry and wild
space walking and anyone you're inside
the spacecraft you use that toilet okay
so what is the P go if you do it in the
spacecraft in the spacecraft it's
collected and then dumped as as he
described you would want to see that
urine dump was cool because it would it
you would dump it in would crystallizing
the Sun would shine on it and it was
really it was beautiful frozen peas
everybody say urine dump hey so you're a
dumping me you know before you hit the
switch and go to the window and watch
yes that's it
so you tell me your pee and it was
orbiting the Earth
apparently yes I never thought of it
that way but yes for a little bit until
it crystal you know it kind of
disappeared well then it would re-enter
the atmosphere well yes yes okay now
that you know the secrets out that's it